- Okay, welcome.
Thank you so much for joining
us for this special event.
What a perfect day to spend
a rainy Friday afternoon
learning about Korean culture
while eating this delicious Korean food.
As the sequel to the talk on Wednesday,
Dr. Myung Chul, a Professor
Emeritus of History
at Dongguk University,
and currently a Professor
of Archeology at the,
I think, Samarkand State
University of Uzbekistan,
will continue to shed light
on Korean history, culture,
art, and religion
in the greater East Asian
and Eurasian context.
Again, in the interest of time,
and for the benefit of the
video recording of today's talk,
I'll ask you to write your questions
on the note being distributed.
Do you guys have notes somewhere?
It'll be distributed,
and I will collect them,
and then I'll read them after the talk.
The format of today's
talk will be the same,
Professor Youn will be
giving a talk for 30 minutes,
which will be translated by my colleague,
Professor Juhn Ahn,
a Scholar of Korea Studies from
the University of Michigan.
This event is sponsored by
the generous gift of Dr. Hwansoo Kim.
And many thanks to council staff,
Kathy, and Injoon, and Dylan.
Without further ado,
let's turn the floor over
to Professor Youn and Professor Ahn.
- Hi, all.
My name is Myung Youn Chul,
I'm a Korean, and historian,
and you see the program,
the video program.
I'm a historian,
and then I'm a poet.
I wrote 14 poet books.
Interesting?
(students and Professor Youn laughing)
The day before yesterday, I have studied,
and with you,
and today is adopt new Tama,
and I'm going to study.
Okay?
And you know that I cannot
speak English well, so,
Professor Ahn.
Okay?
My study is a bit.
Okay.
- I'll try my best to translate.
(Professor Youn laughing)
- And I have time, and
only 30 minutes here.
30 minutes is very important
for me, and to Korean,
and to America, and to the world.
There's a reason, I think that,
and now, okay?
- Okay.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So in the second meeting,
we'll be talking about
Korea's culture and thought,
or ideas.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So as I explained last time on Wednesday,
Korea's culture and thought
is very different from
that of China and Japan.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So as you can see here on this map,
the area of activity that
the Koreans encompassed
included not only the Korean
peninsula, but also Manchuria,
so clearly there had
to be some connections
with the northern steppe
people and their cultures.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Yeah, the large steppe region,
the prairies and the meadows up there,
that's the area that
exerted a lot of influence
on Manchuria, the early
Koreans, who occupied this area.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Right, this is the culture of taigas,
these are the big forests
that occupy the regions in Siberia.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And in the west there was,
of course, Chinese culture.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And so in this eco-environment,
he believed that there's
a great difference
in the way people think
and the way people lived, culturally.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But there's something very important.
So the Korean Peninsula,
obviously, is surrounded by water,
or the ocean, on three sides,
and so it clearly was
influenced by maritime culture.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So this small territory that
we call the Korean Peninsula,
where the influences of
the northern steppes,
the forest cultures of the taigas,
the agricultural-agrarian
societies or cultures of China,
and the maritime culture
from Southeast Asia
and the oceans there,
Korea's where they all meet,
and that's where Korean
civilization first arose.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So, this may not be well known,
but Professor Youn believes that Korea
is the perfect eco-environment
for the reasons that he will
explain and has just explained.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So, naturally, in this
kind of environment,
Korea's culture cannot
but be diverse in nature.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Ahn laughing)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Yeah, so it's a culture that's located
right in between two different
civilizations and cultures,
the one that developed in China,
and the other to the
other side of the strait.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And in the Korean Peninsula,
in terms of the eco-environment,
you have the collection of
very different climates.
So you have the colder climates
that are affiliated with
the northern steppe areas,
and then you also have the areas
that are more heavily affected
by the monsoons down in the south as well.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
You're eating the kimchi that
you see here on the right now.
(students laughing)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Is it good?
(students laughing)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
It's gotta be good,
because kimchi is the
product, and the culmination,
of the mixing of all of
these different influences.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this can be explained
in anthropological terms as well,
but this is a fermentation culture.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And another dish that is loved
by people all over the world
is the dish that was on the left,
that's made from fermented beans,
that's doenjang.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And what you see, yeah, chongkukjang.
It looks like everybody here (laughs)
knows what that is.
(students laughing)
It's nice and spicy.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So, the food obviously is
the culmination product
of all these different
cultural and eco-influences,
and naturally, the
people who consume them,
their culture has to reflect
these influences as well.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So this is the traditional
architecture of Korea.
What you see here in this photo
are the traditional homes
that are still standing
in a place called Jeonju
in the southwestern regions of Korea.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So, Korea has a very
unique housing system,
where they're furnished with
a heating system called Ondol,
where the heat is passed
through underneath the house
to heat the entire house.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
In the south, in addition
to the ondol system,
the heating system,
there's also something called the maru,
and that's the area that
you see here in the photos.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So this is the product of a wisdom
that is the combination of the cultures
of the warm regions of the south
and the cold areas of the north.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So, Korea has the unique
ability of creating a culture
through the combination and the clashes
of different cultures.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Now, I'll talk about faith,
belief, and thought in Korea.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
There is a misconception
that in ancient Korea,
there was no unique
faith, belief, or thought.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But that's not fact.
Around the third or fourth century CE,
Buddhism comes into Korea.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
At the same time, Confucianism
arise in Korea as well,
but it did not exert
much influence in Korea.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I'll ask you all a question.
So there was a kingdom, or a
dynasty, known as proto-Joseon,
which lasted from 15th century
BCE to the 3rd century BCE,
but could a kingdom or dynasty like this
not have left written records or culture?
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I firmly believe that there
is a unique culture, right,
that that existed at the time,
faith and belief that existed at the time.
And I believe that I
can find traces of this
in the archeological records,
and also in the customs of Koreans today.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
You know the word "shamanism," right?
The word shaman is not obviously English,
but a word that comes from Manchuria.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So we can say that shamanism
is a very unique religion or faith
that emerged in the regions
that encompasses Manchuria
and the Korean Peninsula.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Of course, there is traces of shamanism
in the Baikal Lake area,
in the premier mountain ranges,
in that area in Central Asia as well.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I'd like to say a lot of things,
I have a lot to say about the subject,
but I obviously won't have the time.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
If you wanna know more, please
invite me out again. (laughs)
(students laughing)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
The reason why we cannot
but have a culture like this
is because of the eco-environment.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
In every place I went,
there were mountains, there were streams,
and there were large plains.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But they're all very different.
So, one of the unique characteristics
of the mountains, and the
streams, and the plains in Korea
is that they are friendly,
and that's what makes them very,
friendly to human beings,
and this is what makes the
eco-environment of Korea
very unique.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
That's why Koreans are so kind,
and there are so many kind
Koreans in this room right now.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this cannot but be an
old historical tradition.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And in a natural environment like this,
you cannot but develop a very
strong sense of community.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And therefore,
Koreans think of themselves
as one big family.
(page turning)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And I expect that this
kind of belief and thought
will exert greater influence
in the world as well.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
As a historian, I not only
worked on historical facts,
but also thought and faith,
and I've also worked on other
world civilizations as well.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this is because history exists
not only to uncover lost facts,
but because for the sake of
world civilization as a whole,
and its future.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
For me, my family's important,
Koreans are important,
everybody here is important.
Everybody in the world is important.
(page turning)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And so I proffer today a new thought,
and that is the notion
of non-civilization.
- Non-civilization.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- Please remember the
word "non-civilization."
(students laughing)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this is a new theory by Dr. Youn.
Now let's look at the culture of Korea.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
A lot of people have misunderstandings
about Korean culture and
beauty, or aesthetics.
- Okay, I'm sorry.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- As I explained last time,
the culture and thought of Korea
has been misconceived and misrepresented
by Japan and Western scholars.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So Koreans are said to have a lot of Han,
resentment or sorrow,
because it has been subjected
to frequent incursions and
invasions by other people.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Do you like do you like BTS? (laughs)
- Yes? Okay.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- Look at their dance,
how active, and how
much movement there is.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But despite the fact that there is
this very active component
to Korean culture,
we've been taught, misleadingly,
that we are very quiet and
passive, right, and secluded.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But as a historian,
I can tell you that that is
not actually based in fact.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And Koreans are often described as people
who practice toadyism,
or serving the great.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
The only people in that region
that has continued to see themselves
and maintain their
identities for 3,500 years
are Koreans.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And therefore we have a very strong sense
of self-consciousness.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So I refer to the characteristic
of the Korean people
as free-will.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So Korea is misunderstood often
as the land of morning calm,
but I see it as the land of very active.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Have you ever seen this word before,
"Mo-stability" culture?
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- Okay, impossible.
(students laughing)
- That's obvious that you
haven't seen this before,
because I coined the term.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
In the past, Korea's
culture has been described
almost exclusively in terms of stability.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
In our last meeting,
one of your professors, Professor Westoff,
referred to Korea as a stability culture.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But the culture he's referring
to is the culture of the Joseon period,
which only lasted 500 years.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But above that, or before that,
there's 3,000 years of Korean history.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
If you really wanna understand Korea,
the genetic Korea,
you need to go beyond the
500 years of Joseon history
into a steep past.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So that's why I strongly believe
that Korean culture is not
just a culture of stability,
but a culture of mobility and stability,
and that's why I coined
the term mo-stability.
- Okay.
Good.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- So I would love for you
all to remember this word.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And the most representative
kingdom of this kind of culture
is the ancient Korean Kingdom of Koguryo.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And Koguryo is what I studied for my PhD.
(students laughing)
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
(students and Professor Youn laughing)
You may not know,
but I'm actually a very
famous person in Korea,
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
and that's why I was invited
to the greatest university
in the world, Yale.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And he hopes that whatever
he shares with you here,
at this great institution,
will then spread out to
the rest of the world.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And that's why I changed,
I went from one flight to the next,
and made this long journey to Yale.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So, Koguryo culture and
history has deep connections
with Central-Asian history and culture.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
The dance and the music
that are referenced
in the stories about Koguryo
in the ancient sources,
they clearly have a
connection to Central-Asia.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Here in America,
there is a tendency to
lift Japan up on a pedestal
and to idolize it.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I do think that it's worthy of
that kind of respect as well.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But it's a historical fact
that in ancient times,
it was the people who lived
in the Korean Peninsula
who crossed over the strait
into the Japanese archipelago,
who established the earliest civilization.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this is widely known,
because we have evidence in
the archeological remains,
and also in the foundation myths.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
From now on, I'll show you some pictures.
So these are parts of a
golden crown used in Koguryo.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
There must have been a lot,
but we only have a few left.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
So, this is the capital of Koguryo,
but the first and the
second capital of Koguryo
are in Manchuria.
- [Professor Youn] Yeah.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- [Professor Ahn] So this
is a picture of the area
behind the second capital, Gungnae-seong,
and there are a lot of
tombs, as you can see.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So, these capitals had this
very impressive structure
inland.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I have something to say about this.
The European, Japanese,
and Chinese castles
are very big and beautiful.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So Korean castles are big,
but they're not aesthetically pleasing.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
There's a reason.
The castles that were built in Korea
were meant to protect the
people and the commoners,
and not necessarily the elites.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
He thinks that the Koguryo
castles are so much more valuable
in comparison to, say,
the Greek polis, or the
grand European castles,
precisely because these were castles
that were built to protect
the commoners, or the people.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Shouldn't we consider this to
be the origins of democracy?
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I hope you can all start
to develop new ideas
and new perceptions of Korea
with this as the occasion.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So, in this area,
there are about 12,000 of these tombs
that were excavated and
studied by scholars.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So there are about 12 of these pyramids.
The pyramid that you see here
is the one that is the most complete.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I'll offer a very simple
explanation of it.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So, according to the
Koguryo measurement system,
this is a hundred chon.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And it's a right-triangle. (laughs)
- Okay.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- It consists of seven floors.
Each floor consists of three steps.
- Okay.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- And that makes it a total of 21 steps.
And this is the number
that Koreans love the most, 21. (laughs)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
In Korea, when a child is born,
they don't just see that
as the birth of a child,
but the birth of a universe.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So a lot of rituals are performed.
And one of those rituals
is to bind this thread
and create a boundary around the child
into which others are
not permitted to enter.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
For 21 days.
- Okay.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- For Koreans, the number
three, and the number seven
are very, very important numbers.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And so in the foundation myths,
we have structures like
this that are still extant.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I'll go on,
I'll move on.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
This is from the 4th century,
and it's a mural from a Koguryo tomb.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And as you can see here,
there is an army, or a standing
army, that consists of men
outfitted with heavy military technology.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Here, 259 of these mountain
soldiers are depicted.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And these are all mounted soldiers
that are wearing armor
that was made out of iron.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
This one is in Pyungyang, the
other one is in Manchuria.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And what you have here are,
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
so, these are golden arrow tips,
and that is a stirrup,
where you put your feet
when you mount a horse,
that's made out of gold.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
On the left,
what you see is the
representation of a Koguryo woman.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I know the face is pretty,
but I'd like you to focus on the clothing.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And as you can see,
the clothing is very
different from the Hanbok,
or the traditional Korean clothing,
that was worn during the Joseon Period.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And what you see here is
basically an image of somebody
who would be better-suited
for mounting a horse and fighting.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
These are arrows that were made
a thousand years before the Mongol army
was outfitted with these bows and arrows.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
These are all from the Koguryo.
They're very beautiful
murals, found inside --
- Yes, very beautiful.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- I've had the great opportunity
to actually enter these tombs myself
and personally gaze upon these murals.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And of course,
this is all observations that were made
in areas that aren't Korea today,
but in areas outside of.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I just recalled something right now.
(Professor Youn laughing)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
In 1995,
I purchased a horse in North Manchuria,
and I rode it all the way
down to South Manchuria.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And it's because I'm a
real historian. (laughs)
(students laughing)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Because in Korea,
Koreans have forgotten
the horse-riding culture.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And the strong mentality,
they've lost that as well.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And the strong sense of free-will,
they've lost that.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And to experience that for
myself, I purchased the horse,
and made the trek to South Manchuria.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And all of this was documented
in documentaries, and books, and whatnot.
And some of these, the books,
they'll be donated here, to Yale.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And for the students who can read Korean,
he highly recommends that
you take a look at his books.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
They're really fun. (laughs)
On the left, what you see is a bird
that you can pretty much consider
to be something like a phoenix.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
When you see this bird,
do you feel that what you're
witnessing is something static,
or something that is
active, mobile, and moving.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And if you look at his
head, it's tilted up,
and it's gazing far into the distance.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And look at its feet.
The legs and the feet are very tiny,
but the talons dig deep into reality.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
He believes that Gura folk
were able to draw things like this
because they had one foot
strongly planted in reality,
but they were always looking
in the honor for, and
aspiring for greater things.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I'd love to say more, but
the problem is always time.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
These are golden crowns
from the ancient Korean kingdom of Baekje.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
They're very beautiful.
Also golden crowns from Baekje.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And these are bronze crowns, I'm sorry,
gilt-bronze crowns from Baekje.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And shoes.
And more crowns from another
ancient Korean federation,
known as Gaya.
(Professor Youn and
Ahn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I'll offer a brief commentary
on the connections
between Eurasia and Korea.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
As I mentioned briefly last time,
the Asian continent had been
connected for over 5,000 years
in terms of the west and the
east ends of the continent.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Oh, I'm sorry, not 5,000, 50,000.
The road that he just pointed out,
that's the Silk Road,
but that's not the only one,
there are a lot of routes
through which this interaction
between the east and west took place.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So as you can see,
all the routes that interpenetrate
through the Asian continent,
they all culminate in one point,
and that of course is
the Korean Peninsula.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Naturally, Korea has deep
connections with Central Asia.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
The evidence of this connection
you can find in language.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And we call this the
Altaic language connection.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Some linguists do deny the
Altaic language theory.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But it is very clear
that there were people
who used the Altaic languages.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Do you know who Genghis Khan is?
- Chingiz Kan.
- Or it's Chingiz Khan.
- Chingiz Khan, Chingiz Han,
Chingiz K-han.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- In the Altaic language,
rulers or leaders refer
to themselves as Han.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And the names of kingdom or countries,
you often find the word
in the names as well.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
We find references to this
as early as the 5th century.
But since the time of Chingiz Khan,
you see even more people
referring themselves in
high possessions as Han.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
In my research,
I discovered over 39 places
that refer to themselves as Han.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And today, Korea is also
called the Han country.
- Yes, Han connective.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- They refer to the sky,
or the heaven, as Tengri.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
In the Turkish cultural sphere,
they refer to the sky, and
the god of the sky, as Tengri.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I'll skip all the rest,
but I'll focus on just one thing now.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Where's the one place in Eurasia
where a very, very long and protracted war
is taking place right now?
Do you know?
In Central Asia?
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
A very, very --
- Ukraine.
- Yeah, right, it's Ukraine.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
The big sea below Ukraine
is called the Black Sea.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
The Black Sea is a very, very harsh sea.
A long time ago, I took a boat or a ship,
not sure which,
all the way from Korea
to the Mediterranean
into the Black Sea
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
for 90 days.
It was a big ship that he took,
but when he entered the Black Sea,
it was so rough that he couldn't
really navigate it there.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And the sea there was actually black.
And that's why it's called the Black Sea.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But the Turkish referred
to it as the Gara denes.
- Yes.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- Kara means black.
- In Buddhism.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- In Japan, black is kuro.
And as you can see,
there's linguistic
evidence of the connection
between Central Asia all the
way over to China, to Korea,
and of course, Japan.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
In Samarkand, where I am right now,
you find this mural from the 7th century,
and in the mural,
what you see are actually representations
of two envoys from Koguryo.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
In the midst of the
protracted war with China
that lasted 70 years,
Gora actually sent envoys
4,000 miles across the Asian continent
to remote locations like Samarkand.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this is a very remarkable fact.
And this is located right
next to Samarkand University,
where he's working right now.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
Oh.
(students laughing)
A lot of people, (laughs)
a lot of people argue that my face
is the face of Koguryo.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
This is not a joke,
it's for real. (laughs)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
In a place called Kuri,
located not far from Seoul,
there is a bronze statue,
and the model for that
statue is our Professor Youn.
(students laughing)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I'm a historian, so I
base everything on fact.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
We're almost done.
So let's talk about religion,
and religious faith.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
In Eurasia or Central Asia,
they worship the sky,
or heaven, or tengri.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And in the ancient kingdoms of Korea,
the rulers also refer to themselves
as the sons of the sky.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this will cross the
ocean, or the strait,
over into Japan, and the
same thing happens there.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And there are of course
remarkable similarities
between the foundation
myths of Japan and Korea
as a consequence.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
If you look at the Japanese
flag there, it's the sun.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And obviously, in Korea,
we worshiped the sun in
ancient times as well.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
All you need to do is recall
the image of the raft that I took,
that I showed you all in my last lecture.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So these elements, the cosmic
mountain, and the cosmic tree,
these are things that Korea
has in common with Central Asia.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
A unique bronze culture
develops in Manchuria
and the Korean Peninsula.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Around the 12th century BCE,
the bronze culture of the
steppes enters into Korea.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
People in this culture
exerts a heavy influence on their growth
of Korean antiquity.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And I'll show you evidence of this now.
From the 5th, 6th century CE,
all the way down to the 12th century CE,
what you see are these glass
ornaments and glassware,
and these are all imported
items from Persia,
or the Middle East.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
These are golden crowns.
The kingdom that has the
most number of golden crowns
is the ancient Korean kingdom of Silla.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And the connection between
Silla and Central Asia
is very, very deep.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
You all know Excalibur, right?
The sword?
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
A beautiful blade,
like the one that you
see here on the slide.
This was discovered in the
ancient Korean kingdom of Silla.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
In Korea we have this one,
but even in the entire
world, when you look at it,
there are only just a few of these,
as you can see here on this slide.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Why was this discovered in
the Silla capital of Gyeongju?
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
There's no way to really explain it.
And that shows you how deep
the connection between
Central Asia and Silla is.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And so you see a lot of bowls
or dishes that take this shape
in Silla and Gaya.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And they resemble the kinds of glasses,
or the cups that were used by the Vikings,
as you can see with the horns,
and also the ones used by the Mongols.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And if you go to the museum in Tehran,
very similar items and artifacts
you can easily discover.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And in Silla, you can see representations,
as you can see here,
of people of Central Asian origin.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So you can see that there
was frequent interaction
and acceptance of
culture from Central Asia
into ancient Korea.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And now let me talk briefly
about the Japanese islands.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
There's a period called
the Yayoi Period in Japan.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
It's a culture that began
around 4th century BCE.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
It's around this period
that they began to develop agrarianism,
and also bronze culture,
and also state building.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So where did the people
who live in the Japanese archipelago,
where did they come from?
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Did they fly over to the islands?
Obviously not.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
They had to have taken ships over.
So there's not a lot of material artifact
from the Jomon period,
but we have a lot of evidence of Koreans
arriving on the shores
of the Japanese islands
in large numbers during this period.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this is a fact.
For the 4th century CE onwards,
Japan begins to develop its own states.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And so unlike a lot of
other Korean scholars,
he believes that from the
fourth century onwards,
that the Japanese had developed
very strong sense of
civilization and culture.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And I've explained all this very clearly
in my publications already.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And last but not least,
in terms of Korea's relation with Japan,
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
the 70 year war with China,
Koguryo actually loses.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And Baekje will also collapse as well.
And a lot of immigrants from Baekje
will cross the strait
into the Japanese islands.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And immigrants from Koguryo
will also enter Japan as well.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And all of these people will
come together as a community
and establish a new state,
and that is the current Japanese state.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this is my personal opinion,
but he believes that this is
the first unified polity,
or state, in Japan.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
The word nihon, or iribon, means
"the place where the sun rises."
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And I'll show you the
similarities, or the connections,
between Korea and Japan.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So what you see here is a jade ornament,
and a sword, and a
bronze mirror from Japan.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
There was an effort by the Japanese
at the end of the Second World
War to evade the Americans
who were looking for
the treasures of Japan,
the three items that you
see here on this slide,
and the Japanese worked very diligently
to try to keep these out of the reaches
of the U.S. forces at the time.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And so I believe that the
Japanese, really, on the one hand,
are scary,
but also that they have a lot of focus
to be able to pull
something like that off.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
The shoes that you see on the left
are bronze shoes from Japan.
The one that you see on the right there
is from ancient Korea.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And these were found in various locations.
And as you can see on the
left, bronze hats from Japan,
on the right, bronze hats from Korea.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And you can see that the tail
ornament on the hats as well,
there's a remarkable
resemblance between the two.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And you can see that the Gaya people,
who were depicted on the map
right there in the orange,
in the Korean Peninsula,
they traveled over into
the Japanese islands,
and they left behind artifacts
in all the areas that
are marked with the dots
on the Japanese map.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Japan is certainly, no doubt,
a very powerful country,
but we, we should remember
that the formation of
civilization in Japan
was a consequence of all of these Koreans
crossing the strait into
the Japanese islands
during this period.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this is the helmet for a horse
that was discovered in ancient Japan.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this is the helmet for a horse,
oh, we skipped a slide,
but the other one was from Japan,
so you can see the similarities.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Bronze crown from Korea,
bronze crown from Japan.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this is important.
So this is treasure number one in Japan,
this is a seated Buddha,
or Bodhisattva figurine,
a wooden one that is
currently housed in Japan.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this is the most
prized treasure of Japan.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And Carli Aspers once made mention
of the aesthetic qualities of this item.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And I've crossed over to Japan
to actually go look at this statue
on more than 50 occasions.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But let's look at the image on the left.
This is a very important fact.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I'll skip it though. (laughs)
(students laughing)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Now let me talk about Manchuria.
- Yes, Manchuria.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- So, Korea has been heavily influenced
by the cultures that entered
through the nomadic immigrants
from Manchuria and other
parts of Central Asia.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And obviously forged a tight
bond with these people.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And there's an inevitable
geopolitical formation
that existed in Northeast
Asia as a consequence.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
There is the folks of the
steppes in the northwest.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And on the other hand,
there is the great civilizations of China.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And these two civilizations
have constantly been
fighting with each other
and in conflict with each other.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But in the east, there was a
separate eastern civilization.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And even geopolitically speaking,
this is a separate cultural sphere.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So, naturally,
when the Chinese
civilizations became powerful,
a bond, or a connection, or alliance
was naturally formed
between the civilization
up in the northern steppes,
and the civilizations out in the east,
which of course encompasses Korea.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this is a very, very important fact.
So in Manchuria, there were
the Senbi, and also the Kitans.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Ahn chuckling)
In China, it's hard,
it's not frequently admitted,
but Chinese history was
deeply and heavily shaped
by the conquests and influences
of these northern people,
the Senbi and the Kitans.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But the Senbis and the Kitans
lived in the northeast in Manchuria.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
According to historical record
from the mid-6th century,
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
there is a record that says
that the horses of the
Senbi, and the Kitan,
and the Koguryo, are
the same kind of horse.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And I think this I implies
something very, very important.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
There's another important
fact about eastern Manchuria.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
There, the Tungusic people used to live.
The countries or the kingdoms established
by the Tungusic people
are the jin, and the?
- Chen.
- Right, those were Chen.
Yeah.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And so we need to take another second look
at East Asian history.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So let's now take a look at China.
I really believe that Chinese
civilization is great.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Because it's located in the center,
all the different cultural
and material influences
from the peripheries entered into China.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
A lot of people think
that the primary agent
of Chinese history are the Han people.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
The people who are really
responsible for the rise and fall
in the development of Chinese civilization
are these people who are located
on the outskirts of the center,
and through conquest and influence,
they're going to help this
developmental process.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So, I proffer my own theory.
So China is a social,
cultural, and? (chuckles)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Youn and
Ahn speaking in Korean)
And geographical entity,
and not actually a country.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
The first time that China was
used as a name for a country
was through Soong Won.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
China is great, but we
should always remember
that it is a product of
the efforts of many people,
and not just one.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And that's why a new geo-political order
should be established
through the collaboration
of the Han people,
the mongoloids in the east,
and the Turks in the west.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Now we're headed to the
epilogue of my talk.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Korea is a very unique,
longstanding historical community,
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
As I mentioned on Wednesday,
this is a culture, or a community,
an unbroken one that has continued
from time memorial to the present.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
The people who form
the core of Korea today
aren't from the Korean Peninsula,
but from southern Manchuria
and the regions just north
of the Korean Peninsula.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And I've shown this very thoroughly
in my first lecture on Wednesday.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Oh, for those of you who weren't able
to come to the talk on Wednesday,
please do ask your friends
about what I talked about.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
As I mentioned on Wednesday,
I see the ocean surrounding Korea
as a kind of Mediterranean.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Korea is an organic
maritime cultural sphere
that consists not only of the territories
of the Korean Peninsula, the land mass,
but also the surrounding oceans.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Oh, and he also believes that China
is aspiring to be a
maritime culture as well.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Because China was always
a continental entity,
and not necessarily a maritime one.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And that's explains why there
are the frequent clashes
between the Chinese forces today
with the Japanese and the
Americans in the surrounding seas.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And I've talked about all of this
in a very neat and concise way
in a book that I published.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Oh, he wants others to take
into account his research
when they speak of the subject.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I'm a Korean, so I'm deeply
passionate about Korea.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Korea has a very unique ecosystem.
Has a very meaningful culture and history.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this is for real.
(Professors Youn and Ahn laughing)
It's the truth.
- Okay.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- So Korea has a different
thought and culture
from the cultures of China, the northeast,
and also from Japan as well.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But even the Koreans
themselves have lost track of
and forgotten this culture.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And he wants Koreans to
once again recall and know
this very magnificent and great culture
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And I want you all to know it as well.
And he wishes for Korean
history, culture, and thought
to be used as a very
useful and effective tool
in solving a lot of the
problems that we face today.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And that is why I stand
here before you today.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Thank you all very much.
(students applauding)
- Thank you so much.
You are very informative, enlightening,
and a very constructive talk,
and we learned so much from your talk,
two talks.
(Professor Ahn laughing)
Now it's time to get your
questions from the audience.
Those of you who have
written your questions
on the note cards,
you can just forward them to me.
Why did you use Manchuria to describe,
oh, the handwriting, you guys.
(Students and professor Ahn laughing)
(Professor Youn coughing)
- [Student] Manchuria
to describe the location
of the Koguryo tombs?
Okay, apparently I'm reading it.
Why did you use Manchuria to describe
the location of the Koguryo tombs?
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Because the Koguryo capital
was located in what is today
Manchuria, not in Korea.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Yeah, and the origins of the
Korean people, he believes,
is the areas of southern Manchuria
and the areas just north of
the Korean Peninsula. (laughs)
- [Student] Okay, the next one says,
"Have you been to Pyongyang?"
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
- Two times.
- He's been there two times.
- No, no, one time's
Pyongyang, and one time's Keso.
- Oh, so, he's been to Pyongyang once,
and the other trip was to
the old Kora capital, Keso.
- And the Gujyeongson. Three times.
- And Gujyeonson, yeah.
- [Student] And then
the third one here says,
"How can we identify the
ambassadors in the mural,"
oh, I guess the two mural,
"as Koguryo and not Baekje?"
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- There is some dispute and debate
about where the envoys are
from in the mural in Samarkand.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But based on circumstantial
evidence from that period,
it's clear that the envoys
must be envoys from Koguryo.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
The hat, for example.
- And the back too.
- And the belt.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And the sword.
And their shoes.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And so scholars use that as evidence
to conclude that those envoys
are envoys from Koguryo,
and not elsewhere.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
(student speaking Korean)
(students and professors
Youn and Ahn laughing)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Please come to Samarkand, I'll
show you the mural. (laughs)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
It's a beautiful place, Samarkand.
I agree.
- [Assistant] Okay.
- [Student] The next one says,
"Some people might say history
is something that happened in the past,
why should we pay
attention to past things?
We are living in the present.
How should we explain the significance
of studying history to these people?"
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
He believes that history
is the study of the future.
- Yes.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- All the things that are in existence,
they exist not for the past,
not for the present necessarily,
but for the future.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So history is.
Yeah.
So history is a guide that shows you
how we're all going to
be living in the future.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So the history as a guide is,
a standard.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
It's a standard or a paradigm,
and not necessarily a prediction
or kind of fortune telling.
- [Student] This says,
"If the castle was used
to protect the commoners,
what did the elites at that
time use for extra protection?"
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So the Koguryo castle actually consists
of two separate structures.
There's an inner structure
where, of course,
it was reserved for the elite,
but at times of war,
the people who would be living
outside of the castle walls
would bring all of their
valuables into the wall,
and they would occupy the
areas inside the city,
where they will be protected.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So he believes that the history of Korea
is not the history of the few elites,
but rather the history of its people.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
They're all family,
they're not people who
use a different language,
or had different ideas,
but, really, a family.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And that's the difference between Korea
and the other surrounding countries.
- Okay. Now?
- [Student] What stereotype
or misunderstanding of Korea
do you think is most damaging?
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- So, he believes that
the greatest stereotype,
and the worst,
is the one that depicts Koreans
as people of Han, or sorrow,
or melancholy,
and also people who
serve the great, right,
who practice, who have always practiced,
a kind of toadyism to China.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Oh, he thinks his lecture's a success,
given the large number of questions
that he's getting. (laughs)
I agree.
- [Student] Did the Jomon culture
have any cultural influence
on the Korean Peninsula
during the period of migration?
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So, the Jomon culture, or
civilization, is one of the oldest
and most important ancient civilizations.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Busan. The city of Busan that
most of you probably know.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And Ulsan, another city in Korea.
And cultural artifacts of the Jomon Period
were discovered in these Korean cities,
located in the south east.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And based on new genetic evidence,
it's clear that the
people of the Jomon Period
crossed over and intermixed
with the people of the Korean Peninsula.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But Koreans don't acknowledge this,
(Professor Youn laughing)
and don't really know
that this is the fact.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this is a big problem.
- Okay.
- [Student] What outside
cultural influences
do you see permeating
Korean society today?
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- This is difficult to say,
but the Haiyu that you all like,
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I don't see that as a
positive development.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Because Haiyu was heavily
influenced by Western culture.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But the ancient Haiyu, very great.
So he really wants the BTS's of the world
to take into account
the aesthetic and cultural
values of the past,
the Haiyu of the past,
to create new Korean culture
of the present and the future.
- [Student] Is it possible
to have unification
of the two Koreas?
How soon, in your view?
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- He would like to know
who asked the question.
(attendant speaking distantly)
(student laughing)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
So, it's a very difficult question,
but he believes that unification
is absolutely necessary
because we're one people.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
He believes that people
don't just have biological
or physical DNA,
but also a cultural and
historical one as well.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And so he believes that
only through unification
can we create --
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But that's very difficult to achieve.
And that's why there are
so many difficulties.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I've made announcements about
this using my own thoughts.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So we, of course, all want unification,
but for now, what we need to aspire for
is peaceful coexistence,
and creating the foundations
that will allow us to eventually
achieve the highest goal,
which is of course unification.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Because he's a Korean and
he really wants unification,
he went to Borya in today's Russia.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- And he asked a shaman,
and asked a shaman, "When is
Korea going to be unified?"
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And his answer was?
(students laughing)
It'll eventually happen.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Speechless.
The international relations, nobody can.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Yeah, so there's a guy named
George Freeman, very famous.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And he wrote this book.
And 10 years after he published the book,
more than half of what he predicted
didn't actually come true.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So we can't really accurately
predict the future.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
But history, as a larger framework
for understanding the future,
can make some reliable.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Religion does fortune telling, but,
history can make factual predictions.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And so, as a historian,
I truly believe that
unification will happen.
- [Assistant] One last question.
- [Student] "What was it
like to live in Samarkand
and teach at the university there?
Did you face any challenges working
with your colleagues at the department?
Did you enjoy it?"
The person who asked this
question is from there.
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
- Best.
(students laughing)
- [Professor Ahn] You all
got that right? (laughs)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- [Professor Ahn] He believes
that his most ideal community
currently resides there in Samarkand.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
(student speaking distantly)
- [Assistant] Oh my,
you must be so educated.
(students laughing)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- [Professor Ahn] So the
people in Uzbekistan,
they don't just blindly
accept or negate civilization,
they live as a family.
It's a tight-knit community,
and that's why he considers it
to be the most ideal community on earth.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
I didn't go to Samarkand to be a professor
and have an income.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
It's because he wanted to
see for himself, personally,
this ideal community that
he was always yearning for.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And so he's hoping that
based on what he's witnessed
and what he's learned from his time there,
that others will see his views to be true.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
He really likes Uzbekistan.
- [Assistant] What are your last words
for our Yale students?
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- [Professor Ahn] So
there was a big article
about these lectures that
Professor Youn is giving
in Korean newspapers.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And that was a mistake that I made.
I should have waited to hear
all of these wonderful
comments and questions
to share with the community
back at home in Korea,
that would've been more ideal.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
So I thank you all very, very much.
(students clapping)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
(students laughing)
He's really thankful for all
of you having the patience,
and to take all of what he's saying,
soaking this so sincerely,
and then asking all of these questions.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
Why would America be so important?
It's because this is a place
where everything and everyone is gathered.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
(Professor Ahn speaking in Korean)
- Okay.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- And he believes that he can
find the future of humanity
here in the United States.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And the only place where that's possible
is the place right here.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
And this is the place
where we're looking for
the future of humanity.
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- Are you referring to Yale?
- Yes, sir.
(many laughing)
(Professor Youn speaking in Korean)
- [Professor Ahn] And the agents
responsive for doing this,
who will be doing this,
are all of you here in this room.
(everyone clapping)
- Okay, finally we conclude
our two very important talks.
- Okay.
- And it was such an honor
to have you with us at Yale.
And I hope, we hope,
to have you back again in the near future.
- Okay.
- Thank you so much.
- Thanks.
(students applauding)
- Have a wonderful weekend.
Thank you so much, you guys, for coming.
(gentle music)